- [Voiceover] In the last video,
we set up this differential equation
that described an LC circuit,
and now we're gonna go about solving
this second order circuit.
The technique that works here is the same
that worked with first order
ordinary differential equations.
We're looking for a function of I
that makes this whole equation true,
and we're gonna do that
by guessing at an I,
put it back into the equations,
and see if it works.
If it works, we win.
If it doesn't work, we have
to think of something else,
and we keep doing that until we solve it.
So, knowing what I know about derivatives,
and knowing and looking at this equation,
can I guess at a plausible solution?
So what we have here is two things.
We have two terms that
have to add up to zero
for all time,
and so that means that
whatever function I pick for I,
and there's some scaling factors here.
Lemme write this equation like this.
So what I have here is
a scaling factor times I
has to somehow fully subtract
from the second derivative of I.
So these two terms have to
somehow look alike for all time.
There's one function I
know where its derivatives
sort of look like what we started with,
and that's the exponential function.
So I'm actually gonna make a guess.
I'm gonna guess that I of T
is something of the form
some constant times
the exponential of time
with some other scale factor.
Now, K is an adjustable parameter,
and that's an amplitude.
So it tells us how big the signal is,
and what's S?
S is up in the exponent along with T,
and we know that by the time
we take an exponent of anything
that whatever's up here
has to have no units,
so that means that ST, S times T,
has no units,
and that means that S
has units of one over time
so S is a frequency of some sort.
And in particular, it's
gonna be a radian frequency.
It's gonna be in radians per second.
So, S is gonna be called
a natural frequency.
So let's keep working on this.
We're gonna plug I back into our equation,
and see if it works.
So we can plug I straight into here,
and we need the second derivative of I.
Let's first take the first
derivative D, DT of I
equals D, DT of K
E to the ST,
and we can take that derivative,
and that equals K times S
times E to the ST.
So it's also an exponential,
and now we need the second derivative,
so we wanna take the
derivative of this guy,
so second derivative of
I with respect to time
equals the first derivative of S,
K, E to the ST,
and that equals--
Another S comes down,
so it's S squared, K,
E to the ST.
Good, now we have our second derivative.
We can plug that in here,
so let's do that.
So the equation becomes S squared,
K, E to the ST,
plus one over LC,
times K, E to the ST,
equals zero.
Let's do a little factoring.
There's a common term here.
There's a common term.
K, E to the ST,
K to the E, to the ST,
so lemme factor that out.
K, E to the ST
times, what's left?
S squared plus one over LC
equals zero.
Okay, we have how many
adjustable parameters here?
We have K, S.
Those are the two.
L and C are constants that
are values of our circuit.
So, we need to find some values of K and S
that make this equation zero.
Okay, I can make K equal to zero,
and that would mean that zero equals zero,
so our amplitude would be zero.
So if we put nothing in the circuit,
we get nothing out.
Okay, that's totally boring.
So that's not so
interesting of a solution.
Now, does E to the ST ever become zero?
E to something, does it ever become zero?
It never does.
If I let T go to plus infinity,
and S is negative,
then E to the ST would become zero,
but plus infinity time from now
is pretty far in the future,
and I don't wanna wait that long.
So the interesting solution becomes
can we make S squared plus one over LC
equal to zero?
This equation is referred to
as the characteristic equation.
So let's see what happens
when we try to solve this.
Well, the first step of this is
I'm gonna get S squared
equals minus one over LC,
or S equals square root
of minus one over LC.
Uh oh, look what happens here.
We're taking the square
root of a negative number.
So what's gonna happen here?
We're gonna get an imaginary
number for our answer.
I can write this as
square root of minus one
times square root of one over LC,
and that gives me two answers,
and I'm gonna call the first answer S one,
and that's gonna be equal to J,
which is the imaginary number.
That's the square root of minus one
for electrical engineers,
times what?
Times square root of one over LC,
and the other, S two,
is the negative of that,
minus J.
So these are two possible solutions
to our differential equation.
Now, I'm gonna give a nickname
to this expression here
because I don't wanna write it so much.
I'm gonna call this omega knot.
So this is a lower case
omega Greek letter.
This is the capital omega
that we use for Ohms,
but little omega is often used
as this variable here.
So I can say that S one equals
plus J, omega knot,
and S two equals minus J, omega knot.
So we're gonna use this
notation for a little bit,
but just remember I made
that simple substitution.
We have two different roots
that can cause our differential
equation to go to zero.
So when we combine these
into a solution for I,
we're gonna use a
combination of these two.
We don't know which one it is.
It could be both.
So they could be
superimposed on each other,
and this is what superposition is for.
So we're gonna now have,
we need to have K one.
We'll have two constants,
E to the S one T
plus K two, E to the S two T,
and I could also write this as--
Let's fill in some of the numbers here,
K one, E to the plus J,
omega knot, T,
plus K two,
E to the minus, J omega knot, T.
So that's my proposed solution,
and what we need to do now,
we found S.
We found two values of S.
Now we have these two constants.
We gotta work those out.
So, in the next video,
we'll use the initial conditions
to figure out what K one and K two are.